BF pretzels and lederhosen oktoberfest
is serving up all the ingredients that
have made it the world's biggest
traditional festival even though this
year's attendance figures are down 3
million people have visited the
oktoberfest so far that's ten percent
less than last year still the beer tent
operators are content and remain hopeful
at visitor numbers will rise in the
second week guests come from all around
the world we're from Holland when we're
having lots of fun are from New Jersey
nice States of America we're from
Switzerland I'm from South Africa the
Gita fights comes from Germany i knows
the oktoberfest like a few others she's
written two books about the festival and
was the first to publish a psychological
study about the event for several years
she's conducted tours here too
zahnmedizin is the special thing about
oktoberfest is that it combines
tradition with modern rides and it draws
people from around the globe and it's
world famous people usually equate the
Oktoberfest with beer but the event has
far more to offer than that
for instance you can eat like a king in
recent years there's been a greater
emphasis on quality and now there's more
on the menu than traditional hearty
Bavarian cuisine
it's about their vegetarian options as
more and more people are vegetarians or
vegans you can get a vegetarian dish in
every beer tent I've seen tofu schnitzel
and seitan goulash they're catering to
the trend toward eating less meat the
Santa Linton is so vinegar flies outside
the beer tents over 30 stands at the
Oktoberfest also offer vegetarian or
vegan dishes and they're getting on warm
reception deloitte avanza cousin day and
young people want to eat healthier so
they're willing to try a vegan sausage
rides are also a big part of the
oktoberfest each year operators try to
win over customers with new attractions
but some old rides have great staying
power the crinoline is one of the most
spectacular old rides at oktoberfest
it's 89 years old almost 90 and it's the
only carousel with a live brass band the
only life laughs come in a fire
but there are also new attractions this
year like the conga which swings people
up to 45 meters above the ground or the
demonium a haunted house in which riders
zoom from one scary scene to the next
still visitors are mainly interested in
the 14 big beer tents this s equals of
using said with the first big beer tent
with a Bandstand and people singing
along with the brass band dates back to
1898 inside the tents the mood is jovial
this year almost 750,000 litres of beer
was sold in the first week of
oktoberfest almost as much as last year
a liter of beer costs upwards of 10
euros the Stein's or mugs are handed out
by one of 250 servers the brass band
provides just the right atmosphere in
the whole flight and affairs are Louis
admin and has 24 musicians
yeah yeah I'm snogger the old popular
songs are hauled out again and a few
rock and pop numbers at it but so far
there hasn't been one big hit this
oktoberfest it's
but maybe all that will change in the
second week of Oktoberfest until then
last year's big hit is being played a
lot of Munich
oktoberfest combines the modern and the
traditional let the party continue
you